وليد اذا هناك خسائر جديده في صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي في معارك جنوب غزه ماذا في
التفاصيل نعم الاعلان صباح هذا اليوم منذ
دقائق عن ان ثلاثه جنود بينهم جنديان في
كليه الضباط اي ضابطان قد قتلوا في معارك
في جنوب قطاع غزه وبذلك ارتفع مجمل عدد
الجنود والضباط الذين قتلوا منذ بدء
العمليه البريه في قطاع غزه في ال 26 من
اكتوبر الماضي الى
143 جنديا وضابطا واصبح مجمل قتلى الجيش
الاسرائيلي منذ عمليه طوفان الاقصى والحرب
التي تلتها وتدخل يومها الس 76 اليوم اصبح
469 قتيلا هذا ال العدد الجديد من القتلى
مؤشر بنظر الاسرائيليين ايضا الى ضراوه
المعارك المتواصله في جنوبي القطاع
وتحديدا في خانيونس ومحيطها وان كان الجيش
يتحدث ايضا عن ان قواته تواجه مقاومه
ضاريه في شمالي القطاع هذا التطور يضاف
الى ما كان قد اعلنه الجيش يوم امس من انه
قد اكتشف ما وصفها بشبكه انفاق هائله تخدم
وقاده حماس كان مركزها او نقطه الالتقاء
فيها تحت الارض في منطقه ميدان فلسطين وت
قود الى مستشفى الشفاء وتاتي بالكثير من
فتحاتها من منازل لمسؤولين في القسام وفي
حركه حماس وبذلك يقول بانه قد اكتشف حتى
الان نحو 70% من هذه الانفاق في شمالي
قطاع غزه لكنه يعترف بان القتال ضاري وانه
لم يحكم احتلاله بالكامل على هذه المناطق
وان كان قد اعلن بانه تمكن من السيطره على
مقار قياديه للسا قسام في مخيم جباليا
لكنه يقول بانه ما يزال يواجه قتالا ضاريا
في حي الشجاعيه